this podcast and every other podcast
that I make is brought to you by my
supporters on patreon in Paris was the
world premiere of the brand new uh
Assassin's Creed symphonic Adventure as
they are calling it that's cool a uh a
new kind of
um compendium show that's music from
essentially the whole franchise did you
plan it uh nope I was purely a guest
let's sign some stuff and wave to the
audience and do some little little
Austin
um yeah me and Jesper were both there
um did you tell him I said hi
yeah I had to hold him had to hold him
at Bay yeah from replacing me
um and uh but yeah it was it was
um
it was good fun it was it's the show
is essentially a summary of the whole
franchise and they arranged it where the
games appear in chronological order
Origins
origin Odyssey I think Odyssey first
origins
and then yeah I think one and two and
then uh like two also had like
Brotherhood and and um yeah um
Revelations Revelations
uh and then what would that mean next
um
uh Black Flag yeah
oh three yeah well no no I think Black
Flag would be before three Black Flag
three
and then no no syndicate's the end
that's the finale of the show because
that's the most recent uh which was so
universe
unity and then also
um
what am I am I forgetting I still feel
bad that your Assassin's Creed is the
only one I haven't played
just for that I play every other one oh
God Syndicate really is um
it's really they did such a good job
um it's so cool London is a good
environment for a game like that I think
the fault of Syndicate
um not getting played as much which I
don't know if I'm allowed in that is
because Unity was so buggy when it
launched and that thus I think it burns
Syndicate a little bit oh no for sure I
mean I remember explicitly getting the
sense this was nothing official but I
remember getting the sense that
Syndicate had the kind of burden of
being the Redemption for Unity right
like to kobas to go back to brass tacks
you know and it was in many ways they
returned to form it was like let's let
you know because Black Flag shook the
formula up so much and then Unity was
like this this you know unfortunate
train wreck launch which you know that's
a lot of really fun stuff in that game
like I I still enjoyed Unity but it was
super buggy um and it was the premise of
Co-op is also really cool for AFC and
the way they did it too it was very cool
yeah like it their intentions are never
bad it's just a shame that with a game
like that it's you kind of get one
chance and they knew that it had been
rough and yeah so Syndicate was like
let's kind of do one that's it doesn't
reinvent the wheel the way Black Flag
did and it doesn't
um it and it's like more stable let's
try to let's try to not bite off more
than we can chew
um and so it yeah and and it did well
but the thing that blew my mind is that
apparently Valhalla is the best selling
of the entire franchise oh just recently
they announced across 20 million units
sales which is like gotta be over a
billion dollars in Revenue I would think
for Ubisoft I hear about that game a lot
like I feel like that game has managed
to stay relevant uh because they've
supported it with a lot of DLC a lot of
which I think is free
uh and that may be true I don't know I
guess people have done like Norse
mythology so I hear I don't know seems
to be that's in the you know Sony's like
we should make something to compete with
all this freaking Valhalla stuff
um I am going to steal the floor today
largely Austin I have not yeah I haven't
looked at the Metacritic
um so hello everyone oh I did I haven't
I haven't seen any scores whatsoever
um hello everyone at home we are
recording the day that the um God of War
Ragnarok embargo broke and I was
supposed to go into the office
uh it was like an opt-in thing where you
could go and like watch the countdown
for the Metacritic with I think 200
people ended up rsvping but then I had
work to do last night so I didn't get to
bed until four so didn't do that
um so then I've gotten a lot of texts
which make me suspect that people
probably like it but
um I mean but it all honestly I don't
know
I mean
you have
a very unique perspective here as
someone who has both written reviews and
is deeply familiar with the goings on
there and someone who has incredibly
behind the scenes knowledge of this game
so I feel like the idea that you would
be shocked by a review
like a tidal wave of reviews is
impossible like I feel like you would
have a pretty good sense going in of the
background of reviewing
so it's it's complicated I've spoken
about this on episodes before right
where it's like when you're
you know I've been playing the game for
the last two years like I've seen it in
many stages
Etc
um and when you have that background
which I imagine has happened for you as
well I just feel like it's been hard for
me to look at it objectively like I
would as press there are definitely some
things that I'm like this is [ __ ]
awesome no matter what but in a lot of
cases I'm like oh that changed oh I need
to tell somebody about this oh I need to
take a note about that like whatever
um so I wish they'd kept that I there is
one thing that I really miss uh which is
there was a period of time where Odin's
Ravens weren't animated so they would
just fly around the screen like jpegs
like that like t-pos yeah Ravens and as
soon as they took those out I was like
oh why
um definitely missed that put that back
in but no I look I would be shocked if
it's not getting
in the 8 to 10 range is there some
reason why you're avoiding looking at
Medical because I wanted to do it for
the show I wanted to do it right now oh
well then [ __ ] open it up okay let's
do it I again
I actually don't know what it was I'm
sure it's I'm sure it's updated since
um and then let me know it's the same
I'm not looking at it I'm trying not to
look at it so I can screen share with
you you want me to just uh hit you with
a link
here we go here we go here we go I still
haven't read it I still haven't looked
I'm just trying to avoid it and then I
gotta pull you over here for the
recording I'm gonna make that bigger I
can't okay get rid of those porn tabs
here we go that's a 94.
my God
frankly a little disappointing it could
have been higher
oh my God that's six whole points which
to be frank is the writing spot I
I
think
um I think that that might have even
been like like some people like we just
you'd love to get around to 95 which it
is
do you know uh do you know uh do you
remember offhand uh what the first one
launched at I'm sure that the number
evolves over time slowly but like do you
remember also in 94 which like holy [ __ ]
but like look so basically what you're
saying is everybody just copy pasted and
did absolutely nothing new yeah the
game's exactly the same oh my God I'm
shaking currently I I think this is a
it's a really interesting experience
because
um
so I always feel like I have to give the
context I didn't work on this game a ton
I I was just about to say but then I
stopped myself I haven't gone asked but
yeah like sorry I never really remember
what's the works on it I am allowed to
say that I worked on the accessibility
stuff which I did
like I I pitched and helped iterate some
literal features of the game some
gameplay mechanics
um for writing
I think I'm allowed to say
I'm not allowed to say I'm not allowed
to say what I I can say um
I wrote some my
supportive content and I don't I'm not
allowed to say what
um I'm pretty sure when it's like so
when the text is like drag left to lower
gamma you're like that was me exactly
yeah
amazing you've come a long way yeah I'm
really proud of you yes it's been years
in the making and I'm so my pride comes
a lot more from like I'm a part of the
studio I worked on this game that's
[ __ ] crazy but it's more so on behalf
of like
the people that I work with who I who
were on it non-stop I saw this journey
happen and I was in all the meetings and
I watched this for the last two and a
bit years or no almost three years
um no it is two and they must have been
well underway with it when you joined I
would imagine oh for sure yeah
um and that's awesome but it's also I
was realizing this today when I was
thinking about why the Metacritic score
uh matters and this is probably a very
unique perspective that's like only to
people who went from journalism to
uh
is that you're working in depth I'm like
having trouble speaking
um oh I love it so
when you you work in game reviews
whatever
people always say the Metacritic School
shouldn't matter shouldn't matter who
cares about the Metacritic school it's
just like it's you know it's an
aggregate what the [ __ ] does it matter
and the responsibility will develop his
care and the journalism response which I
think I probably even thought at some
point was
well developers care because they get
bonuses tied to it their companies
shouldn't give them bonuses tied to it
it's not that at all the the reason that
I care about this Metacritic school I
don't get a bonus tight to this game
it's because and I only realized this
literally today why it matters of having
previous like who [ __ ] cares it's
just an aggregate who cares
um is because it's you're literally like
your life's Legacy like it's everything
I did to lead me up to the point uh I'm
gonna stop crying to work at Santa
Monica Studio
it's like reflected in
people liking it like it's just like
yeah the tireless work of a [ __ ] ton of
people
that's just it we we share the pet peeve
for when people
don't like a game and then they
it's not even if they don't like it it's
even worse when they they're like ah it
could have been better it's like not
even it's like anything short of
ravenous excitement somehow gets mixed
into this idea of oh I guess the devs
you know it didn't work hard enough or
didn't care or they [ __ ] it up or they
suck or totally fill in some like super
reductive thing as if as if everybody
didn't kill themselves working on this
thing it's positively you know in many
cases like people really do sacrifice a
lot uh especially the the more senior
leadership type positions where people
you know they Eric was in the office
every day even through the pandemic he
went into the office to work every
[ __ ] day like
yeah it's and it's also we have people
on the team who like sold their houses
and moved their whole lives to La like
just before a pandemic hit to work on
this game
um again it's that's the perspective
that I have today is very different of
like this isn't
a bunch of
people's opinions who cares like it's so
easy to dismiss that when you work in
press of like why does it matter it it
it matters because it's years and years
and years
just aggregated and it's still silly
like it's still a score that I still
think is just a bunch of people's
opinions and I don't love the Metacritic
system of aggregating I mean when you
review games and you have to give a
review a number it [ __ ] sucks it's
really hard to take 4 000 words and be
like oh I don't know an eight like
that's it's an awful process it's it I
wish we could get rid of them in general
but I think it's I don't know I've
always you've mentioned that before and
I I go back and forth because I
understand that giving it a number
creates this illusion of it being
somehow objective or measurable as if
every time you reviewed it if you met if
you reviewed it again 10 years from now
or if you gave it to a reviewer who
comes from a different background or a
different life or someone who has kids
and doesn't someone who played for 10
hours straight versus someone who played
10 one hour increments it's as if all
those things shouldn't matter and the
review score will always come out the
same yeah IGN's was very positive yeah
it's like oh Simon did it
um you know and and we know that's not
true you know somebody it's the closest
you can get to that but no it's not true
but it's entirely it really is entirely
subjective and that's why I've always
thought your advice to follow
um
reviewers uh that you've kind of find an
inherent resonance with is a very
um interesting and good piece of advice
uh because then it sort of
that if someone gives it like you just
said Simon if Simon gives this a 10 out
of 10 that is informed by theoretically
having read prior ones and that's that's
a really
uh that makes that number actually have
meaning that makes that number actually
relevant to something because you're
like oh I remember Simon also hated this
game
that was a controversy recently about uh
Modern Warfare like one of the it
happens all the time with Call of Duty
it's so stupid one of the Call of Duty's
got a worse score than the previous one
even though the community believes the
current one is worse or whatever
um and they're like how can this
possibly happen and it's like it's just
two different people reviewed the game
so that's it if you had reviewed them
that's the order you would put them in
but sometimes the person who's reviewing
this one like the one that came out this
year didn't even play the last one
because and that's a problem that I
think happens with um with FIFA and with
Call of Duty or the annualized
franchises it that sometimes the
die-hards get bored they don't want to
review the game anymore so someone else
doesn't that become an argument in favor
of Metacritic insofar as if you have
like somebody who's playing God of War
for the first time ever they never
played the prior one they never played
any of the earlier iterations of the
franchise and they're like blown away or
somebody that's very unimpressed because
they don't have like this investment or
all the different points of data yes
bearing in mind that a number is going
to be subjective but over time in the
same way that like statistics about
human populations can can be accurate
but they don't necessarily map to every
individual person within a sample group
that's true yeah so then like by by
having Metacritic as an aggregate again
it's just reducting reducing a game to a
scores
just especially when something is
emotionally resonant as I think God of
War Ragnarok is I feel like that's very
complicated but it's the closest that
you can get to the likelihood of having
one person who's played every single
game one person who it's their first
game one person who doesn't know
anything about Call of Duty one person
who only plays first person shooters and
and there is always and also the the
different perspectives you know like
there's there's Outlets that review only
PlayStation games so they're really
measuring it against other PlayStation
games there's people that are reviewing
only AAA games there's people that are
reviewing like you know Etc et cetera
um I I think yeah that it there's no
perfect system but I I don't know that I
can think of a better one like
especially because of the way the laws
of averages work
anything above like 80 means you're
getting really consistently good reviews
so to be in the mid 90s is like means
that you know you're obviously getting
astonishingly great reviews it's like
it's just hard to maintain an average
you know you learn every kid in school
learns you have an A and then one
[ __ ] D in the whole semester yeah uh
will will pull the whole thing down so
shockingly I think I I mean I never
would have expected a hundred because
that's like impossible what is it Toy
Story 3 or something was one of the only
like on uh Rotten Tomatoes to have 100
ever or something
um
do we know what the highest ever
Metacritic I think Ocarina of Time is
really high up there Metacritic
yeah I just Googled it as well
yeah Ocarina of Time 99 yeah there's
like one guy somewhere that's like oh I
think it's I think it's very good Tony
Hawk's Pro skated two is second that's
so funny great game but it's just so
funny in Grand Theft Auto 4 Soul Calibur
Grand Theft Auto 4 again say there's any
on here that are surprised Mario Galaxy
Mario Galaxy 2 Red Dead Redemption 2 GTA
5 GTA 5 disco Elysium oh I'm so glad
disco elysium's there yeah that's the
one I was just about to say that's the
one that's like a slightly surprising
yeah just because it's very Niche but
that's an example of a one that's like
complicated it probably has less reviews
than a game like God of War Ragnarok but
all the reviewers who are going to opt
in to review that game are going to
already be interested in the premise of
it for the most part or they're going to
be reviewers who like like an art I mean
disco at least seems so [ __ ] good but
I would think though that this I mean I
don't know a list like this done
properly would also wait by a number of
reviews like because if a game has one
review of 100 it's gonna do better than
Ocarina of Time and there probably is
some game that has one review of 100
that no one's ever heard of
maybe I don't know or do you need to
have multiple to get a score
well that's a fair point I don't know
how Metacritic works because there was
one time where like somebody told me
something about how it works and I like
said that publicly and then Metacritic
emailed me and was like this isn't true
and I was like oh well okay then we
don't know how it works I don't know how
[ __ ] Metacritic works
but in any case
um
it yeah it's been a very wonderful
Journey for a lot of of very very hard
working people and uh obviously the
review score is coming today are nowhere
near as exciting to me as the game
coming out next week and getting to see
people stream it and play it and react
to it because I think it's very very
very good it is I don't know how many
times I've played through it at this
point
um
no just bits and pieces because
sometimes they will the entire level's
not there and I have to jump through
[ __ ] that wasn't there or whatever
um
the some of some of the the things that
have changed yeah it's been like boss
fights that
but barely animated or emotional cut
scenes where people's faces didn't move
yet like a lot of fairy funny stuff that
I'm sad is like just lost to the ether
of the previous builds that you can no
longer activate
um
but yeah today I didn't know that I've
worked on a lot of games where we were
scrambling internally to get a review
build
um you know stood up in in working order
knowing full well that there was going
to be a bunch of work that happens after
that that's what the actual player like
launch build would be and there's a
little gap between there and that
there's inevitably
bugs are even missing content that would
be part of review build it's it's going
to vary game to game but did you ever
have it as a like the kinds of things
you're talking about of like missing
animations and things like that did you
ever have review builds come back in
your reviewing days where it came also
with the caveat of like obviously some
of this stuff is not finished almost
every single one almost that still
happens today when I get um a game early
that they'll usually say known issues or
this this and this that are then fixed
in usually the day one patch
um so yeah
is that the kind of thing as a reviewer
you feel like
should I
I mention it so if I mention it yeah
yeah if I encounter the error that
they're mentioning I will say this
occurred however they said that this is
part of this building will be fixed
that's what I would I would say I did
have uh one game that I gave a negative
score to as a Ubisoft game um
werewolves within it was that that VR
version of Mafia or werewolf
um ah yeah and it was really really fun
but so buggy like there were these
things where you'd have to join a Lobby
and sometimes like the menu button
wouldn't work so everyone would have to
leave and jump back in and that happened
all the time and the community was bug
solving because the whole thing was
based on microphones so if I had
something not work someone else would be
like oh I had that yesterday here's how
you fix that and because the game is so
fun I emailed Ubisoft and I was like I
can try and hold on this review
if you're going to fix these things
within the next probably a week and then
I could publish it when I fixed and
reflect that but for now I kind of have
to give this a negative score because
it's like you have to the part of the
gameplay is bug fixes effectively
um and they said they wouldn't have it
done at time they were like we might
have this done in the next two weeks
it'll be fixed eventually but that that
is what it is so I just have to publish
it knowing the bugs were there it seems
like one that'd be like great to have an
opportunity to update for that kind of
thing but
if you know that they're there and
that's the thing that people can buy
right now that's the thing you have to
review it's a complicated part of it um
and I'm glad I don't have to do it
anymore it was very fun in my early 20s
but now like
it's really tireless and thankless
um it's fun to write I've always liked
writing you get to write about a thing
you like and that's fun but otherwise
it's it's a shitload of work and it's
I'm really glad that we gave uh
reviewers access weeks ago because to
have to rush through again can really
hide the experience well and how many
people how many how many reviews
actually have finished the game at the
time of writing the review I mean I
would imagine so many games I look at
you know like especially if you're
talking a red dead an Elden ring you
just go it's not like they gave it to
them two months before most people
didn't finish Elden ring yeah like how
could they How could a reviewer possibly
have I know I also would argue you don't
have to have finished most games to size
them up uh you know like a lot of games
you you can get a sense you know some
earlier than most some earlier than
others I mean but at some point you're
like
I'm not gonna suddenly like a game I'm
not liking my thing is four hours if I
like it four hours in I'm probably gonna
understand what the whole game is four
hours but most games unless it's like an
indie game I mean like of a triple A
Story based thing it's gonna be four
hours
um and I agree that you can usually know
what a game is going to be but there's
something like uh Ragnarok because the
story is so
important
it would be like not finishing The Last
of Us
yeah I mean that's that's
certain I haven't read any reviews yet
obviously but I would imagine a lot of
them finish data um I mean I know people
at uh like a number of people with
Platinum did and I'm probably gonna go
do that on my actual
PS5 I don't have a it's funny people
keep asking me for codes obviously all
right some of the DMS that I've gotten
they're so funny like there's been
people who are like there was this one
guy who's like hey just wanted to reach
out because I'd really like uh Santa
Monica Studio to sponsor my channel
um they have 30 000 subscribers and the
deal is that if you pay me and you give
me a code then I'll play the game but
like a full genuine DM saying that and I
was like shoot your shot man my God like
Jesus I mean look I always admire you
know the worst that can ever happen is
someone say no or not responds it wasn't
right I always he wasn't I always have
yeah I always have admiration for you
know Moxie as it were that's right
um but
um
um it is an interesting it is an
interesting pitch kind of knowing
the scale of other channels out there
that don't
I don't even get I ordered that and
nobody said anyone to I wouldn't I
wouldn't know that's marketing they're
so separate but uh I don't know if
anyone's been paid to do anything to do
with the game
yeah exactly I mean it don't even do
that
spot too I don't know either I mean I
got paid for a death stranding campaign
but
otherwise nothing to do with I mean you
know Sony page usually it's enough to
just give someone a code or like a
collector's edition yeah what I'm saying
is I don't even have a code I don't get
a code until launch date God damn it
yeah I know I don't know why people
think I can get them codes because
otherwise it's been can you give me the
email address for somebody you can give
me a code and like I can't just give out
my colleagues email addresses to a
hundred people I can't do that like it
that would be really shitty of me it's
just very funny to me that someone would
even think
like I I don't do that with people I
know uh because I don't know I know yeah
people I know and complete strangers
well okay I did ask you did uh so did
Mike come on I did In fairness because I
saw Mike do it I'll just own up to that
because he's not here uh I'll I'll fully
confess I was riding his coattails on
that one that's fair enough but
um yeah if he were here I'd 100 deny
that but I respect it yeah
yeah oh yeah for sure the great irony
you're gonna send Troy a code I'm sure
of it I don't get codes I know he wasn't
the last one
that's true that's true I'm fairly
certain I remember killing his character
yes you would have he and Nolan yes
which is so funny oh yeah but yes to to
put a button on it it's um
I wasn't sure how I feel going in today
how long is the game sorry well that
that I was essentially changing
according to reviews uh
I don't think I'm allowed to answer the
question so it has to be this is what
people on the internet have been saying
I think I don't even know what the
internal answer to that is just given
that the the last one I think was
somewhere in the like 15 to 20 hour
range maybe as high as 30 if yeah I
think it took I've finished it in three
days and it took me 25 hours
but you also probably
were thorough I would think no
I did all the other [ __ ] after I
finished the camp yeah because I was
trying to finish it before it came out
which was which sucks which is hot so I
finished it really fast just Breeze
through the story
and that yeah it was 25 or 23 Maybe
I hold on let me see how long
to beat.com the most useful website but
the thing about I use that website all
the time the thing about yeah 20 to 30
yeah 51 for the completionist 20 of
which is just fighting the [ __ ]
batteries yeah it's so hard that was
that was the divide that was the line
for me the helheim valkyrie I was like
uh this is not doable by normal people
it's very fair that's the thing it's not
hard
in a like Jesus is a [ __ ] way it
just it's like unapologetically going
you you will love it a narrow margin for
error here or non-existent and have fun
the thing I love about the Valkyries and
I've watched people fight them a bunch
of times because it's fun to watch the
thing that I really like about it is
anyone who is an aggressive player
you have to watch him like over the
period of an hour trying to get through
that final fight
learn to stop themselves for being so
aggressive maybe they're people who come
from like fps's or something and they
just want to run in and attack all the
time and you absolutely can't you have
to wait and you watch them like humble
themselves over time and slowly be like
okay I have to be more patient and it
takes a really long time for people to
do it I guess that's the that's the
souls like influence of button mashing
or like rolling you know yeah I mean
because that's that's true of a lot of I
remember going through it's very
different and but I remember on Fallen
order
having like I hadn't really played a
lightsaber game
that wasn't basically button mashy on
some level that was one where it was
like no no you'll die if you just think
you can hack and slash through every
enemy and and God of War had the same
had the same quality you're just
vulnerable enough I also thought they
did such a good job at
um again I haven't played Ragnarok I'm
assuming that it's this and and more
presumably I think it takes the the core
of the previous game and builds on it in
almost every way I saw that IGN sort of
summary said essentially exactly that
that that that it doesn't
fix what wasn't broken but it also is
not afraid to introduce new ideas those
differences I mean I think the
the pacing is very different
um
that's definitely I don't know I think
it's a really fun just go ahead and
assume you can say anything
yeah yeah that's great how can you get
fired you just wrote the UI what are you
gonna speak exactly that's it what else
do I know
no but I I loved that
um
it even like atreus is not
um window dressing in terms of like
actual combat mechanics like there's a
real it really felt like I was
leveraging both characters
in a way that you had to like you had to
kind of learn and get and get good at
and then it made it it was one of those
classic you know where's Troy when you
want to talk about narrative dissonance
but that idea that that the the
character Arc really did feel folded
into my own increased skills with
commanding both characters at once uh
and that's that's really that's really
cool because historically games like
this were like get through all the
fighty bits whatever and then we'll have
cool cutscenes yes uh and and boy did
that that not was that not the case on
this one and I fully anticipate
um maybe the big innovation of Ragnarok
is camera Cuts maybe they're like oh we
learned that you can uh you can
perspective yeah turns out that that was
all born of ignorance they were like I
just don't know I guess if you don't
have film stock you just roll forever
nope none of those uh which is
I think I would love to actually have
like quarter Eric sit down and talk
about it because I think that that is
people already expect it to be hot I
think it is infinitely Harder Than
People realize they're the the things
that like you could do in most games you
have to be like well we can't do that
because we can't cut it's it's a lot uh
very very as someone who grew up
where loading screens were like never
never mind it was like the PS4
well yeah I mean it's true the the the
uh still a lot of games they're they're
very normal in most games even I would
just think about bloodborne it was like
two minutes
so long yeah oh yeah I mean I and I and
I remember I remember they became an
extension of the gameplay I'll never
forget 20 plus years ago playing playing
EverQuest where you know it's like you
accidentally aggro an enemy that's out
of your range and you can't deal with
but if you just run to those edge of the
Zone you'll you'll zone out and Escape
them but you'll you'll in the game's
geography sense you'll cross one inch
and all threats vanish and you know that
became part of the like that's how that
that became part of strategy it actually
players embraced this as like oh let's
how can we exploit this it's not even a
bug it's just sort of it's just a
necessary evil and you know that was
always like you said minutes long
especially remember like when cd-rom's
first first became a thing and the
drives themselves weren't that fast by
comparison to today so like it felt and
you'd fear you'd feel it like you'd go
to do something and hear the drive I
sort of label gloriously kicked to life
and so just the lack of loading screens
never mind the continuity between
different sort of modes of gameplay on
and off the boat in and out of cut
scenes all the crazy kind of I don't
know if you want to call them QuickTime
events but the the way the kind of big
set pieces are designed with all the all
the kind of more or more choreographed
camera work and stuff versus the free
roaming open world or whatever kind of
stuff the fact that it's all done so
well I mean I started I I opened up 2018
God of War a few months ago and [ __ ]
around for for a couple hours
figuring oh I should replay it knowing
Ragnarok is coming and then of course I
never finished it but
um I did finish it once upon a time and
even even revisiting it I was like man
it's so slick it's so impressive because
even the classic like
the like the the classic modern
um like narrow passageway hide the hide
the loading
um in the you know I always think of
like Tomb Raider or Uncharted or they
did it a lot in plague's tale where your
your um uh your kind of like narrowing
and the kind of camera gets up on there
it's like such a classic way to hide
moving well that's awesome not always
the case I think people think that um
those are loading every time but a lot
of the time it's just pacing or it's
trying to make sure that you don't get
lost in so you're in a new area and you
know that there's a difference between
the two areas sure they aren't always
loading screens
it's like the dead space elevator
yeah right I mean Mass Effect elevator
remember how long that used to take
yeah I remember that was one of the
biggest moment everybody changes on the
uh I always wished kind of like the boat
in God of War is some of my favorite
moments in the game just the just the
way that the storytelling kind of
becomes the focus but you're still very
much doing something and you're you're
even exploring and learning about the
environment and trying to figure out
what to do that stuff was written very
late too I don't know what it was but I
didn't work am I can you correct me if
I'm wrong I swear I remember a GDC talk
or maybe a podcast or something with I
assume Corey I don't maybe it was a
designer uh working but like lower on
the on the like what like a design
director or somebody I can't remember
who said this but
I read I I came across like a thing that
there that was basically a Hail Mary uh
of there was like boat based combat and
stuff there were enemies and and it was
there was for Tech related reasons it
was never satisfying or they couldn't
quite get it to work satisfactorily and
the whole idea of what if they just
essentially talk so that we don't have
to [ __ ] some kind of fast travel or
something like we can't be fighting out
in the water because it's just not
working or getting in and out of the
maybe it was like there was swimming and
getting in and out of the boat was
proving problematic something like that
that they spoke about and then it was
this was like a solution that ended up
being far better than the thing it was
fixing I don't doubt that yeah I'm not
sure if that's true or not but I do know
that a lot of the the boat riding came
later on
um and like that's such a credit to
mimir as a character and his voice actor
that he a lot of that content is made me
a law like him sharing stories about
I don't know North Smith or the the God
of War take on it and the fact that he
keeps those also captivating
is a massive credit to that actor I
can't even imagine how many lines he
actually had in 2018. not to mention
also just the subtle
but so welcome thing that so many games
either didn't have the capacity for or
Tech issues or just didn't think to try
of
you get off the boat you go do your you
know local objective that you're chasing
down and you get back in the boat and
they're like anyway what are we saying I
love yeah yeah ah man me too that was
such I remember thinking how has this
not been the norm for the last 20 years
because there's nothing that big of a
leap about it but I can't remember any
game
kind of having kind of like a separate
timeline going oh you're this far along
in the conversation and all the
interruptions they're going to keep
coming back to it you know I don't know
how they did it from a text from
something along those lines very
complicated The Narrative design uh uh
stuff that that basically triggers like
when those specific box or or I don't
know what the most basic way to say that
phrase is when the lines of dialogue a
triggered is very very very complicated
a lot of game writing I imagine
everywhere uh is
but how do we convey this to the player
and how does it go with gameplay it can
be really really technical like it can
be very like we need to follow these
rules it takes a lot of the passion out
of writing because a lot of it like
you're not just like and they felt these
emotions they're like okay but when did
that Arc fall so that it pays off for
this act or this boss fight can this
happen here or what like it's very very
technical work
um so then just getting to write
something where a character just has an
opinion
it's it's just really fun because it's
most of your your job is actually not
that in a lot of cases I think that
maybe maybe Indies are a little bit more
like that but it's also like do we have
the budget for this scene can we afford
to do this thing well and also just the
open world any game that even is
approaching open world starts to
introduce a lot of complexity where it's
like
you have to have all these states that
the system is tracking of you know uh is
this a character is this a conversation
or is this a line that makes sense if
the player has gone off and done X
already so we have to make sure that if
that if the player has done X and now
the character mentioning a it no longer
works that that those two systems
actually are talking to each other and
and that way you don't end up with
somebody being like how cool is so and
so and they've been dead for the last
two hours of gameplay you know like
there's that I remember
you know a lot of games
you can find the edges of the success of
those systems uh if you're really
thorough like even on a like a mass
effect or something which is a you know
all things considered those are pretty
damn polished games but like there's
just so much writing that you know
sometimes you can kind of go do a thing
and then ask someone a question and it's
like
I've already done that mission and
they're they're like briefing me on it
or something along those lines you go
you know this is this is a technical
writing a book or a short story or a
poem or a screenplay is like probably
what most writers want to do I think
that like writing a game is a lot of
working with other departments and
making sure that the whole giant Beast
that you're trying to make functions
yeah like I said very technical will you
be in a position to walk through a lot
of that inside nature of of those
questions like like once it's out in the
world do you know yet where you're kind
of boundaries are in terms of how
transparent you can be with these kinds
of like especially the tech related
because I would so love to unpack
probably allowed to talk about that
stuff anyway what I can't do and why I
have to be really careful about saying
anything
is um
because I exist in a very unusual bubble
of my audience size almost making me
press so it's it's not that like other
devs could probably tweet something that
I can't because if I do it has the risk
of making a news headline more people
are likely to see it and even on my own
channel or streams or whatever it's
almost like I'm a media Outlet so I have
to get media approval to be able to talk
to myself uh which is like very weird
and complicated so that's why I'm so
careful
um because I don't want to I don't want
to speak on behalf of the studio which
is weird because I work there um without
PR being okay with things that I'm
saying where again it wouldn't matter
with someone else is on [ __ ] Twitter
but like everybody else at the studio
has to get approval to do a podcast to
talk about God of War
I'm not approving every episode of play
watch listen it's it's comparable I
think to like you know Troy and Neil and
people like that when a when The Last of
Us comes out having to to go through
quite a few approvals yeah but I don't
because
it play which listen is not a about it's
not a God of War podcast so it's it's
just it's just I live in a very weird
bubble where I err on the side of
caution and I think they want me to also
but like I really am being more careful
oh I see I yeah I think I misunderstood
so in other words you
like obviously we've never had to seek
approvals we've always spoken and then
obviously we just things get cut if they
think if if they if they yeah if they
fly too close to the Sun yeah
um
but what you're saying is theoretically
if you tested the limits of that that
might change the rules here uh well no
it's that I it's more that um for you to
get fired again I wouldn't get fired for
it immediately but it's more that uh I
don't want to be a [ __ ] like I don't
want to be difficult for my team I don't
want to like give PR or marketing a
headache my job is so much more
important to me than the podcast or
YouTube channel so it's more that
I want to be respectful of the people I
work with than anything else so it's
it's yeah it's just I'm insulted
it's just that I recognize that I live
in a weird spot where like I I think I'm
allowed to upload a YouTube video of me
playing the first hour
I I what I was told no and then they're
like maybe yes because other people will
maybe we don't know and um again people
could be like that's weird but it's
because I am media
and it's almost like I'm two people in
that I'm media also talking to a Game
Dev so that it needs to be approved
because I'm media um even though would
you want to like given your position
you've obviously streamed a million
things before this one you have a unique
relationship with would it even is it
fun to to do that I don't think I want
to because I have to walk on eggshells
the whole stream like like I am now is
easier to do when it's a conversation
with another person but if I'm streaming
God of War
I'd be like uh oh can I say that and I
feel like that's easy to watch on a
podcast then it is on a stream it'd be
one of those it'd be one of those uh
streamers where they forget there's
people watching so there's you just be
play it's just your face just watching
the game that's what it's like when I've
done reactions to all of the trailers or
conferences the whole time just like
smiling
things yeah cool that's the thing that
happened so I think I can talk about
technical aspects of of game writing
also in part because I'm currently doing
a little bit of work on another
franchise entirely that isn't even at
Sony like I'm just doing a thing in my
spare time as a contract and I've done
that twice before too I just don't talk
about what they are so I can talk about
post Post Release though when
unannounced project comes out and I
invariably play it and hold it over Mike
who plays it two years later of course
um
uh
and I'm like so this part
can you explain to me this from a
technical standpoint is that a thing
that you'd be like no I can't it all
have to be approved by Sony PL
interesting interesting well I'm gonna
ask again maybe I could but I would I
don't want to [ __ ] them up but that's it
I just don't want to screw up the team
of people that I work with so I'm here
to uh be celebratory and be very proud
of the team that I work with and be
proud of my even tiny input on Ragnarok
this is well that's yeah but that's why
that's actually exactly highlight sort
of why because certainly speaking only
for myself the kinds of questions I
would ask they're invariably stemming
from here's the thing I found really
cool and interesting and your answer
would be a oh here's the thing that all
these people came together and did and
that's why we're really proud of it and
like it's not that I'm trying to tee up
you you know no I know you're not right
it would be more yeah well or that
either for dirt not looking for
clickbait and also not looking for just
like teeing you up in a like to to sit
there and and you know sort of brag or
or like but it would be more just here's
the thing that really worked and I'd
love to know how this works uh that that
would be where I'd be coming from and
it's interesting to know I'm gauging how
heartbroken future me needs to be when
I'm told I can't ask about it I would
say you could try and I will figure it
out here's a here's an Earnest because I
I really you know obviously I love that
on this show we talk about everything
and and and for the love of God tell me
if you've started on Endor but pause I
haven't yet uh I'm waiting till it all
comes out
oh my God this last one I'm waiting I've
already seen a lot of tweets about this
but like
I genuinely got full-blown Goosebumps
from the last five seconds of
yesterday's episode where it was just
like [ __ ] what a payoff good God it is
so well written I think I'm going to
wait until they're all out and
watch the first three and then I think
it's like and then two and then there's
like an order in which people are
suggesting you watch them like their
films but I'm gonna wait till they're up
I've heard I think there's gonna be 12
total and then it's basically four
groups of three but it's not like
they're so Standalone that you shouldn't
just I'm just watch the first two are a
bit weak
well no it's the first three as a unit
but I don't think they're weak it's just
one of those that it's clearly
it's a it's it's playing chess and not
trying to win in the first four moves
it's it's going
you'll you'll thank me later it it felt
like that to me I went in like going
Star Wars has broken my heart 30 times
in a row and it and it and so even
overcoming my skepticism
um despite the fact I love Rogue one a
lot it's like the one outlier that I
just have Unapologetic love for and this
being attached to it I thought okay it's
got a good shot but I went in with a
pretty high dose skepticism and it just
overwhelmingly felt like at its slowest
it's not that it's slow it's that
they're putting pieces in place and have
the confidence to go four episodes from
now you'll thank me and it and it has
delivered every step of the way but yeah
have not done that
no it they felt and look I have a lot of
Sympathy for the difficulty of 100
making a giant production these are
highly scrutinized there's a lot of
people a lot of cooks in the kitchen in
fact this one feels like
they somehow dodged that it feels very
personal it feels like the kind of
script that a small very trusted group
or even one person goes off and writes
and comes back and it's like you can't
pull any thread without pulling it all
apart and I don't actually know what
their process was so it could be it's
just as Cooks in the kitchen itis as all
the rest but just somehow came out
brilliantly anyway all that said
all that was an aside on I love when we
talk about all things non-video games as
well but because my favorite
I think moments of play watch listen are
when we really kind of lean on each
other's
specialized knowledge on things
I would even go
you can tell me if this is something
you're comfortable with or is even
appropriate or even possible you could
shoot this down any number of ways but
if there were things that
when playing the game the if there's
things that I'm dying to ask about I
would be happy to preemptively say can
you get permission to talk about this
because I'm dying to ask and it would be
useful to talk like so that you're not
in a position of having to make the call
you can actually find out officially I
think that it would be easy to this is
such a weird conversation for us to have
as part of the podcast I know I like
planning a future episode um
I would record it and I would send it to
Sony and be like can we publish this
that's what I okay
fair fair because I I really value like
more and more the last year and a half
like as as events have started to come
up and like you know I was at game
soundcon here in La which is an event
that's kind of like the audio track of
GDC as its own uh conference
um as last week
um and then you know packs type things
GDC type things
um every year or for the last year as
those have started to become more
routinely in person again
um
I I've just constantly had people come
up and go dude love playwatch listen or
like I see it on my own channel comments
that are like oh I have a question on
playwatch listen you mentioned a lot of
luck can you go in more detail like in
one of your more kind of composers yes I
definitely think the value of the show
is not the stupid [ __ ] we talk about but
in fact the knowledge that we share
that's the thing I really I really I I
really I take a lot of joy and like even
dare I
feel bold enough to feel it like pride
in the idea that we really do all have
different takes and and and and and
um there's just no question that that
you know one of the reasons why I take
such such uh pride in my prior
collaborations with Santa Monica in
particular is that like it's a [ __ ]
just unbelievable studio and like
anything that can be gleaned from their
their their model I I have a um I have a
friend whose birthday was a few weeks
ago and he works at naughty dog as an
audio programmer and um his sort of like
senior audio director who's in charge of
essentially all things audio for Naughty
Dog was at the party and you know it's
just sitting there for an hour asking
him questions about like the Ellie
breathing system in in Last of Us Part
Two dude that's the best thing about
like a dice you were telling me that you
spoke to one of the designers on
um it takes two and I was like I would
[ __ ] love to do that I want to just
talk to them about how they made that
game it's so impressive like and I think
that that's also just a testament to why
we're in the industry
and that's why I'm forever interested in
how video games are made and what other
people are doing especially now that the
more I learn is like how different
different Studios function it's
tremendous for sure yeah that the whole
game Maker's notebook part of my podcast
palette is uh is so much fun for that
exact reason that it takes two one with
Philip Erickson was especially good
because it made me it blew me away how
insanely well like for you because of
Joseph Ferris like at the game awards
creating this immediate image of like
the kind of
crackpot sort of like
yeah at best he's that at best he's like
the chaotic genius best case scenario
and then like slightly more cynical
people would go that guy must be a
nightmare and what I love is that you
talk to people with hazel light and
they're like first off he's great but
also
the I was so floored in talking with
their their audio director and and kind
of seeing your sound designer about just
how well organized and scoped they were
was constantly like oh yeah we started
to realize we were trending behind in it
so yeah we cut this we cut that and we
stayed perfectly made that game which is
so [ __ ] hard it was crazy it was it
was one of those I kept going this must
have been really stressful and it was
like no we just trimmed you know five
percent when we realized and it was just
like he just he isn't here's the thing
that I will say about Santa Monica
Studio that you can write a news
headline about if you want of all of the
places I've ever worked I've never felt
more like I've been treated like a human
and I feel like that leads into people
making good video games I feel like
terrible yes I feel like people care
about me and care about each other I I
feel like if anyone on the team is sick
or whatever we're like it's cool we'll
catch you up there's no really like we
really could have used you today it's
not and I've had that in so many
environments that seem so much less
important working on [ __ ] that doesn't
cost anywhere near as much as God of War
[ __ ] Ragnarok
um and I feel like that that positivity
grants you even more of a sense of Pride
and of course I'm only speaking for
myself I don't know what everybody
else's experiences like in other
departments whatever but my manager is
uh anoop is a wonderful kind caring
person who
if I have something I need to ask he
will talk to me about it for as long as
I need everyone on my team is that it's
just the environment is so
like where all a bunch of people with a
bunch of different lives working on
something to try to make it good and I
feel like that's reflected in the
quality of the work it's just it's a
really [ __ ] great place to work and
you know what I think I think because of
Santa Monica naughty dog you know a few
others as industry leaders very much
like like they are they are for many
people the the city on the hill they are
working towards in their career or if
nothing else they just represent a
parallel example of of
you know a shining example of how it's
ought to be because they they are are
Studios that that people routinely you
know have like I've just talked to so
many people that have had such positive
experiences at a bunch of different
Studios
um and even Studios that they you I read
all these headlines that make it sound
like it's hell on Earth and I actually
talk to people there and and you realize
you know
it's hard to generalize uh yeah I mean
that could be somebody who feels that
way at the company I work at who feels
like a talent I don't I don't know how
everybody feels like that yeah
it's extremely positive what I was going
to say is is you know
the nice thing is because it's a small
enough industry and because it's a very
competitive industry in which
um there is a lot of competition amongst
hiring entities for the best possible
Talent like if you're like for example
speaking from my side of it if you're a
senior level from an experience and how
many games you've shipped kind of
standpoint audio person like a person in
a position to be hired as a studio audio
director where you've you've shipped
games or you've hired and managed
composers sound designers voice uh you
know like booking and managing voice
sessions that kind of thing that there
is such a shortage industry-wide of
people with high level experience in
that that there is just like if you if
you announce you are if if you are an
audio director at any one of these you
know Ubisoft EA Microsoft who who's got
some pretty serious experience and you
even give a hint that you're kind of on
the market it's like they will be
beating down your door so aggressively
because there's a real shortage of that
and the reason the result is
because a lot of departments you know
there's just there's a it's an expanding
growing industry there's a lot of
pressure to get good people everywhere
the result is when you treat people
amazingly it forces other companies to
have to treat people amazingly because
you're like if I have the choice between
two jobs that are offering me comparable
salaries but this one has a reputation
for being really awesome to its people
then I'm gonna pick them like what I
would take it would take a pretty big
either massive pay bump or you know like
promotion that you weren't being
otherwise offered with to overcome like
a really shitty reputation so what
you're saying I'm happy to see I see it
across just about every Studio that that
I work like I see I go to a lot of
stand-ups
um over the course of you know the last
several years of different projects at
different stages of development and like
I can't think of a single one that isn't
how you just described where they're
they are really making sure everybody's
heard and seen everybody's like if
somebody needs time a lot of companies
have more or less no questions asked
like you if someone's like I'm dealing
with a thing a lot of people right now
are taking a full month off which is
[ __ ] awesome yeah but we also get uh
like usually in August they give you
um Wellness days it's just like hey
everybody take a break which is like
media never did any of this [ __ ] like my
God yeah
yeah like I'm a I'm a big believer and
people you know
like I I there's a lot of schools of
thought here and as a freelancer I don't
like the argument of
if I agree to X contract that so and so
some other colleague of mine would deem
unacceptable that I'm somehow harming
collectively all composers that is a
that is a thread I have seen pushed
repeatedly I vehemently disagree with
that a lot of words for free I'm I only
am where I am today because I worked for
free yeah I've heard you say that and I
I there's no way I would have gotten
experience if I didn't work for free
Genova Chen when he was making his uh
thesis
called flow 15 years ago at we were both
students and he said I have 500 to pay
you for music and I said this is
basically one you know
poor student shuffling money to a
different poor student it doesn't really
feel right so I said tell you what keep
half I appreciate it I I was not used to
anywhere near that kind of payment in
those days but I also thought I feel
weird it feels like what is it for I
already have everything I need it's an
electronic score I'm not going and
hiring an orchestra or something so like
that's not it's just
it's just a gesture so I thought how
about we split it so I told him go take
your boyfriend girlfriend best friend
parents whatever to like a super super
indulgent dinner
uh I'll take the 250 and uh and and
that'll be that and and like five years
later he told me that was why he hired
me like he told me that comment was the
and no idea we were like at the journey
launch when he was like by the way back
when we did flow like as students not
even the PlayStation version
um this was the thing that made me
realize you were the guy for the the
project and I didn't I didn't occur to
me at the time and it was one of those
where I thought well
I should tell this story publicly more
often than because the the story I keep
hearing pushed is that I I was like
undercutting competition or I was this
or that and I was like people have to
make decisions that's right for them uh
you're being compassionate
yeah that was a decision that was not
made on the basis of like I don't I
don't know I don't even know if he was
considering someone else and they were
like I'll take the 500 and and like even
if that was the case it it you you
you're only responsible especially as a
freelancer for your own decisions yeah
in that way but you definitely
you know it's different for
non-freelancers and that's why I like
the these Studios that the culture
definitely has shifted towards one of of
you know like my favorite kind of
studios are the let's work really hard
let's really all like let's let's not
[ __ ] around here we want to make
something awesome and and Sweat Equity
is a thing but recognize we are also
people living lives and life sometimes
will rear its head in ways that we
should all make sure we've kind of got
each other's back when that happens and
and and be compassionate to
circumstances and not you know make it
feel like the only thing that matters to
any of us at all times 24 7 is this game
anything else should fall by the wayside
like let's strike a balance and be
compassionate to each other's different
relationships to that balance and some
people are going to be different places
on that some people are going to live
and die for the game and want to work 24
7 on it and you know nights and weekends
or whatever and some people are like
five o'clock I pick up my kids I won't
you won't hear from me again till 9am
and both both are okay
yeah I mean sometimes like if something
occurs to me after hours which it does
all the time I'll like message people uh
or send an email or something and be
like hey
pitch whatever
um but every time I'm like don't reply
to this until 9am like every time like
please do not respond do not feel
compelled to respond if I'm working late
you do not have to also work late uh and
I do that every single time and I feel
like I will do the same thing like just
and I imagine some people
yeah exactly like that to me that's a
healthy uh there's one Studio that I
really love where that you know they
have these
uh I can't really get into any specifics
but there's a there's a there's a studio
where they do these really they they do
these like they like work on whatever
you want Sprints where you know normally
it's like the Milestones are very
targeted on here's what we're hoping to
achieve and it'll be baked into
publisher contracts of like by this
Milestone these systems will be working
this amount of narrative will be
complete like a lot of games will have a
fairly parsed out Milestone schedules
that are being decided ahead of time and
or revised as we go uh and because I get
handed that all the time as a composer
that's like by this date we need these
levels done by this date we need these
levels done musically because they just
have a large schedule of all the
different bits broken up over the course
of the game
but periodically this one particular
Studio I'll eventually be able to talk
about it like they'll just tell the team
for this week
anything you want to work on is that's
all fair game and then they'll do like a
show and tell of
what so what it all what did you decide
to work on this person was like there's
been this system that's not high
priority but it's been bugging me
because it's not working right and it
won't be needed till later but I finally
got it working check this out all the
rest of people in the stand up are like
oh my God that's so exciting I'm gonna
take advantage of that isn't it like God
I know exactly what I would do if I was
given that week that's definitely like a
thing that I'm like I would do exactly
this one thing that is exactly that's
like a thing that I need to do but it
hasn't been able to be tough
pretty awesome TGC did when the
collector's edition of of like the TGC
Trilogy came out uh you know after
Journey ship that had flow and flower on
it it also has on there like the three
or four game jams that they made that
are like terrible but amazing
um I wanted to ask off that Austin said
like today's obviously a
a cool day for me that I think I'll
probably spend the afternoon I mean I
have another meeting but
um reading positive things on the
internet and just feeling wild about it
again because of that sense of sort of
Legacy that like you were saying it's
Santa Monica Studio does have a lot of
really senior people who've been in the
games in every industry for such a long
time and I you know I'm so passionate
about video games that people will just
drop a game they worked on be like oh
when I worked on Far Cry 2 and I go what
and I'm like I I'll be that person for a
junior one day I'll be like I worked on
God of War Ragnarok that's so [ __ ]
cool
um and and Sliders didn't write
themselves again it's fine you can I'll
allow it I don't think they're gonna
make a news headlight out of that it's
all good gamma slide this one's me I
wrote g-a-m-m-a they call in a favor
over at IGN I need you to publish this
headline never mind that it's just
slightly false
um
did you I have to open any any releases
in particular like I imagine Journey's a
big one where you were like waiting for
the Embargo to drop like was there an
anticipation of any do you do it for
every game or is it because you're
working on a lot of games as a composer
yeah it's always it's always uh fun and
some some companies
uh kind of ritualize it I think I
remember Mike actually mentioning that
they have kind of like their it's like
beer and pizza day or whatever we did
breakfast tacos yeah we also have a
countdown to launch next week that I'm
really excited about where like I'm
going into the office while we wait for
the actual countdown timer pretty much
yeah I think that's gonna be fun and
then we have our wrap party next week
it's all very exciting
yeah so those kinds of little things are
uh can be great launch parties all that
kind of thing are are
um
uh tend to be very special in fact I
remember the flower I didn't work on
flower but I remember I went to the
flower launch party as a as a friend of
that game company and as someone who had
kind of play tested it along the way and
was very excited about it
um I remember going to the
um
the flower launch party in Genova goes
you have a second and giving me the like
one second elevator pitch on what the
next game was going to be and going we
should get dinner and I'd love to tell
you about it sure I've asked you this
before but what was that elevator
picture Journey what is that it was a
game where you are he goes he goes
um I want to see if I can take if I can
distill Joseph Campbell's mono myth into
a series of like of of of playable
moments where the player has to uh
Traverse a landscape and can encounter
another player
and have like a really almost like
spiritually positive experience his goal
was I want to see if I can instill
genuine love between two strangers
because he goes all
all uh like uh multiplayer or even Co-op
experiences are seemingly on some level
antagonistic and he goes I wonder if I
can make people
like in Genova terms he would basically
say like I wonder if I can make
strangers fall in love
um and I remember it was like go on it
was like I'll get dinner I'll tell you
that's actually very powerful because I
do feel like journey is probably the
closest I have ever been to to that
feeling of you don't know who they are
they don't actually talk to you but the
companionship is there almost
instantaneously
and no one can do anything to negate it
it has to be there you can't really
antagonize and journey that's that's
really cool the fact that there's still
players to this day who have their white
cloaks that go on and go looking for
newbies you know to like show them
around and show them where all the
hidden glyphs are and like yeah it it
appealed to your
your best nature and rewarded you for
doing so it was a game that that that
really kind of like gamified our our
best version of ourselves and and he he
had that was that was the pitch and I
remember going so good luck with that
buddy I know that's so impressive to
have that as the foundation
oh that's so cool like to that that that
is if you think about it it is an
iteration well In fairness to them like
it was also kind of an iteration Beyond
flower of
flower gamified can I just make the
world more beautiful and this was
essentially can I do that in a sense
with someone else it was kind of just
what's the next step like yeah you're
right it's [ __ ] never mind yeah it's
actually super easy
yeah no yeah it was it was uh it was a
very impressive it was one of those
where I remember feeling distinctly
I was in my mid-20s and I thought as
someone who's been a lifelong gamer and
has felt my taste of what I'm looking
for in games change I thought as a gamer
this feels like where I'm at in life now
this is the kind of game I'm looking for
and I haven't found and I was astonished
that I would be lucky enough to be part
of but just even as a gamer I thought
this is a thing I'm I'd love to play and
there was that voice of me going
if they can pull it off because that
sounds impossible uh that just seemed so
lofty I mean even still 10 years later
it's like wow that is
it's not like that became a whole genre
it's kind of it's kind of esoterically
yeah
um but to your question
the journey review embargo was Far and
Away the most memorable of those I've
ever experienced because
I had zero sense of if
people would like it if people yeah if
it was going to resonate because I just
thought it was this rare thing where it
felt like we did what we wanted to do it
felt like the game we wanted to make we
didn't have all these apologies of like
man if only there was you know this
thing is busted and we know it and we're
gonna patch it or like it really felt
like with all the schedule extensions
and obviously it was a brutal
development for TGC I mean you know
there's a lot of stories you can people
can find about how it was not easy on
the team but
I think most of us and certainly myself
felt like
for all the challenges the game that
shipped is basically the game we want to
wake make what we don't know is if
that's universally or even broadly in
any sense appealing to other people it's
like I made a dish where I combined
these things that I've never really
tasted other people and I don't know if
that's a good flavor but I did make the
thing I went to make and so it was like
the reviews could be this is a bunch of
typical [ __ ] Indie pretentious
walking simulator I was fully prepared
for that or I thought look I think I
think that they did a good job I I'd
like to think I did a good job and
there's hopefully going to be some
contingency to the reviewers that say
the same and then for that day to come
out and it was just like this wall of
tense like gaming has changed I was like
that I wasn't prepared for and I've
never had an experience like that since
then that is especially because it was
also just very unusual that the music
had such a kind of privileged position
in the overall gameplay that every
review mentioned me and it was I was not
accustomed to that yeah you know first
time I was ever mentioned in a review
ever was in 2008.
uh when I had a film Premiere at
Sundance and Hollywood Reporter and
variety both mentioned me in their
review during Sundance and one hated the
score and one loved no way and they both
mentioned me
um wow as part of their praise slash wow
this is so weird
um yeah it was it was and I remember
that was before smartphones and stuff so
I had to go to like the public internet
like rentable IMAX to see Hollywood
Reporter roast you yeah yeah it was it
was it was thank God Todd McCarthy at
variety was like the score really
supports the movie they both loved the
movie so the director was on cloud nine
yeah and he totally trolled me he goes
oh my God you have to go read The
Hollywood Reporter because he goes we
couldn't have bought a better review
like it was so good and then like the
very end of it it goes the the overly
sentimental score by Westerner Austin
winter because it's like the movie was
set in Jordan and the virtually everyone
on the movie was from Jordan or from the
Middle East in general the director was
born in Amman and we made a conscious
choice and stand by it like this is a
universal story let's try to tell it in
a kind of Cinema language and not in a
don't don't try to make it feel like oh
this is some quaint regional thing and
go all Jordanian with the music let's
try to show this could take place
anywhere on the planet and the use the
kind of conventional language of Cinema
to achieve that that was the thing that
was actually the director's pitch to me
the Jordanian directors pitch to me and
I and we loved it we recorded at Warner
Brothers scoring stage big Lush
Hollywood orchestras dream come true 22
years old three months out of University
damn and um and um yeah it was a dream
of a lifetime I mean it was one of the
best experience I mean queen ran you
have Jordan came to our Premiere in um
unbelievable experience one of the best
movies ever it's called captain and
um yeah when it was not nominated for
best foreign film at the Oscars L.A
times actually wrote an article saying
like they're obviously not watching the
movies because this should have been
nominated for Best Picture never mind to
win foreign film damn
um it was such a special film anyway
that um yeah it was the first time
seeing my name in print
in a review that was glowing glowing
glowing glowing and then they were like
yeah but the Western score thing I don't
know about that uh was really funny it
was like my career's over I just
pictured like all of Hollywood like
holding up these magazines of The
Hollywood Reporter going I'm gonna take
note of this guy's name put him on our
[ __ ] list like you have these irrational
horror feelings and and it makes you
realize okay reviews they only matter so
much and it's a healthy lesson to learn
even when they're really positive or you
go
by far the best I will speak for you I'm
going to mansplain to you great
the far more valuable than the
Metacritic and all that are going to be
the tweets and the the DMS and the like
this game like I learned to love again
you know I tried to touch on this before
but I think I glossed over it myself was
review embargo is one thing
I've been like kind of like weirdly
nervous about it all day I don't know
why mostly just very proud but next week
is the bigger deal for sure the media
amount is a lot less than the people who
play it and love it and
like I really do
care about the story a lot like I feel
very strongly about it
um and it I guess we had leaks I didn't
even really know about it until my mom
called me and told me
which I haven't heard any and I've had
I've certainly had no spoilage uh I just
don't spend a lot of time on Twitter
anymore so I don't see a lot of that
stuff
um obviously there were
updates internally on how that's being
handled also but I found out because my
mom called me and told me
um and that sucks uh so I'm just gonna
mute all keywords on all of the comments
so nobody can spoil anything for like
the next
three months or whatever but um I'm just
yeah I'm really excited to see people
play it and and stream it and um I'll
probably spend a lot of time watching
Let's Plays of of people finishing the
game or some of the like really
sentimental moments and I'm really
really excited about that that is a
really that is definitely that I do love
that about twitch uh um watching people
play like app Zoo for the first time or
Journey or any number I love even just
like I'll never forget watching Brian
and Amelia uh play the last was part two
and like when they got to some of the
real gut punch moments so that it like
it like they like publicly melted down
like in a in a very
in a very internal collapse kind of way
in a in a like I need to be quiet for
the next couple hours sort of way not in
a explosive radioactive way but it was
like
I'm not I'm not super okay right now in
the best way like as the best possible
review yeah how visceral some of the
moments in that game were and watching
it I
maybe I'm just naturally empathetic or
something but I got so wrapped up in
their response it was like playing the
game for the first time again that's
awesome and it was just like and I
didn't even work on that game but just
thinking
this this is a really
uh special thing that's like a side
order effect and what and what's great
is that could happen you could get
tagged in a tweet about this game five
years from now that someone like late to
the party but holy [ __ ] when X happened
that like I I'm just a changed person uh
and and it will be just as
touching five years from now when that
tweet shows up or whatever
future Tech five years from now when
we're all living on Mars and on the Moon
Yeah I think that's the Legacy thing I
keep talking about and I think that's
probably the biggest shift from all the
other work I've done in my entire career
is that everything else disappeared fast
even the like written content that I had
done
um that was fictional like even that
stuff just by virtue of the way the
media companies I worked for operated so
it's gone so [ __ ] fast and I think my
favorite thing about working in Dev
versus working in media is a group of
hundreds of people working on something
for years and having all of it come out
at once to this big explosion rather
than yep we made a YouTube video for an
hour and there it is no one remembers it
next week uh and it's it that life feels
like it has full meaning which is wild
but it it does it's uh
infinitely more impactful for me let
alone for all the other people who
experience it which is it's just a very
cool thing to be a part of
yeah absolutely I I couldn't agree more
can't wait for Mike to not play it
yeah
we should definitely start holding
auditions for our developer like
directory it's definitely Romney there's
no way it's not wrong like I've already
got all of you replaced in my head
obviously
I know Grant yeah definitely Grant I can
imagine how different this show would be
we get Nolan we get Grand and we get
Robbie it's a very different show oh no
I guess it has to be Greg rather than
Nolan can't can't we what about you
there's got to be like nothing would be
more hilarious than it's on your channel
but you're also not on the show like
who's the the easiest to replace me with
you just swap me out because it has to
be somebody who's not a writer director
it's just a writer which is like
actually a lot less common first I was
gonna go yeah I was I was about to say
Ken Levine but you're right if it's
purely because I mean
um thank you though I really appreciate
that correlation yeah it's Ken Levine
yeah yeah my Alter Ego is Ken Levine I'm
right up there
well look if you're gonna swap me out
for Grant kirkhope who is obviously
Superior in all ways all right I think
he would strongly argue with you about
that
except that no one would know what he's
saying because when he talks he's like
uh but yeah it's uh no I'm saying the
upgrade all yeah you know yeah Ken is an
upgrade right Greg Miller is an upgrade
Greg what's up Craig Romney's an upgrade
we're all thoroughly replaceable yeah
all right but to that to that end I will
say
um
just special shout out to
um I remember a few years ago when
Captain uh when uh civil war came out
the movie the MCU MCU movie Captain
America Civil War
it came out the same day as Uncharted 4.
and what was extremely noteworthy and
was a first ever uh was that here you
had one of the biggest releases
of the Year movie wise and one of the
biggest releases of the year game wise
were both scored by Henry Jackman and
the fact they came out on the same day
wow what a big day was was a was it
astonishing and incredibly rare thing
to that end
um
big shout out to my dear friend and
highly admired colleague uh bear
McCreary for not only scoring God of War
Ragnarok for sure one of the if not the
biggest game release of 2022 and and
like probably I'm sure there's like
whether it's budget or scope or like
it's surely like among the like kind of
more substantial games probably ever I
don't think so yeah
um just like by virtue of the franchise
it's a part of and all that but to be
that on hot on the heels of rings of
power quite literally the biggest TV
show ever I think it rings of power as
well
yes oh I didn't know that God yeah
there's lots of there's huge swaths of
the score where you go this this gives
me some serious god of war fights
actually
um like yeah it's so to you know
Bears you know bear manages a big
operation he's very talented he's very
hard working he's a guy that actually
really does try to make his scores he
tries to imbue them with something that
you know gives them some kind of angle
he doesn't just go okay you know it's a
Hollywood thing let's do the big
Hollywood thing and it rings of power is
in fact probably the closest to him just
trying to be fundamentally traditional
and at minimum it's just it's so it's so
tuneful there's like 50 really genuinely
memorable Melodies which is that is the
Hallmark of the great traditional scores
and God of War has that same he is
incredible and I think he's done an
incredible job on Ragnarok as well I
can't wait I've heard none of it I know
that I know that it was an unbelievably
huge undertaking uh yeah we had a
listening party and maybe like Macho
something
um and it I like it was my first time
hearing it I was like all of it in one
piece that is and he's like holy [ __ ]
it's like chills the whole time you're
very good at what he does uh yeah he he
has he has hit a benchmark this year
that I I would put forth no composer has
ever uh like to to have scored yeah
essentially the biggest like because
I think that I think that with all due
respect to Henry Jackman the the tale of
Civil War and Uncharted 4 are shorter
than
rings of power like culturally speaking
like though these are both events on a
level that rings of power especially is
like love it or hate it it's just so
talked about and so and it's like and
and they're so amazingly enough that's
not my perspective at all I would think
that rings of power almost doesn't exist
because I see nobody talk about it
a lot I've admittedly seen mostly people
talking about it talking about how much
they hate it
um but uh but point being like just it's
a splash it's an asteroid crashing into
the ocean regardless of your feelings
like it's just such and the the scope of
it I mean it's a half a billion dollar
it's the most expensive ever made isn't
it yeah it's like well over 60 million
per episode oh my God like it's it's
truly mind-blowing like I remember when
when Joss whedon's Firefly uh pilot
budget came out like pilot was like 9
million or something 10 million five
yeah it was and it was like that it was
like the highest budget
pilot ever by a mile it was like this
big deal that's amazing because it
doesn't come across like it's super high
budget
well for the time yeah yes but no I I
mean that in a complimentary way it
feels so like
in children's I mean they basically
built the entire spaceship yeah this was
20 years ago Network television very
different from the HBO model of like the
super Prestige thing that you know Game
of Thrones and all those kind of paved
the way for a whole new level of like
like ratcheting things up but anyway
regardless of one's opinion I personally
have mixed feelings at best on rings of
power except on the score to me the
score is the the only truly
unimpeachable aspect of it
um and God of War I expect to love
everything about including the score I
just can't not give a shout out bear and
I talk pretty often and uh I I just hold
him in such high regard and I'm so happy
for him he was a guy that my
relationship with him 20 years ago when
I was at University he had he had
graduated USC just ahead of me and all
the unit and he was just starting
Battlestar Galactica and all the
professors were super proud he was like
the star Alum because you know he had
gone off and was doing this noteworthy
thing pretty soon out of school and they
were all very out and the work was
really good it was very striking and
very distinctive to this day it's a
score that people still talking about
like very very memorable very unique and
so everything that I did that was
supposedly cool they'd go oh that was
like this one time bear when he was my
student and so I didn't know this guy
and I hated him and then a couple years
later we were both graduated I you know
like he had been he had been out of
school a few years I had relatively
recently graduated and I got asked at an
alumni event to introduce him and we met
backstage five seconds before I walked
out on stage and I told a whole speech
about how I hated this guy so much
because I couldn't do anything without
people comparing me to him and then
later I realized oh he's a badass
they're complimenting me uh and it made
me like flip a corner and then we became
good friends and now we talk all the
time and I think he's awesome so you
guys should get married that's a great
uh relationship origin story right there
yeah no it was it was and he didn't know
any of this I literally walked out on
stage and he was hearing this for the
first time
because they didn't know who I was he
had no clue who I was that's amazing
this was many years ago but yeah very
happy for him I think he has done such
great work uh on the on the first game
and I'm sure it only goes I can't wait
to hear it I think so very biased um on
that note I have to get back to work
because Sam won't work to be done thank
you Austin uh Mike was busy Troy I think
just finished traveling
Troy was out of town for like a hundred
years yeah we did enjoy a very lovely
dinner in multiple dinners in London you
guys have multiple dinners [ __ ] all
right and breakfasts and yeah we we had
we had like a little Soiree in London
and it was glorious but he was very
excited to come home and see his kid
like yeah he was really really eager to
be with his boy it was gone for a long
time and it was kind of killing him well
hopefully we'll have him next week we
shall see and yeah by next week the game
will be out so hopefully you guys can
have played a little bit of it I would
love that um all right this is playlist
and I'm alone I'm videoing him right now
that's awesome he's a composer and
everyone else is gone
okay bye
[Music]
[Music]